hello freak [ __ ] I'm from a culture
that used to be malign and then I
thought wasn't anymore and then very
recently things have gotten weird again
yeah it's really easy to say the Jews
are responsible for a large problem part
of the problem in the world today I've
seen it a lot lately and I used to be
like really inappropriate thinking and
talking just twenty years ago it used to
be very taboo and it is not anymore and
it's it's it's weird it's very weird
it's definitely I you know I I don't
take stuff anti-semitism anti-semitism
is like the closest I come to believing
in magic because it's like it's like I'm
not a big miss little guy but like
anti-semitism has never gone away it
just has and I could see if you're an
anti-semite you're going the evil of the
Jews is the closest I come to believing
in magic because they just never stopped
being evil like I just don't understand
how this never goes away it never goes
away it's so [ __ ] weird like no
matter where Jews have lived no matter
how assimilated they've been you know
the Jews in Berlin were the most
assimilated Jews in history they they
didn't they were known for having
Christmas trees and eating pork and that
they would describe these like Christmas
parties or only be Jews because the
Germans wouldn't go but it would be all
of them worship it I mean celebrating
Christmas they were the most assimilated
Jews ever and that was the epicenter of
the Nazi movement yeah so it follows the
Jews and I mean I know that sure at
least one of your lists negative like no
the Jews follow it but it's like it's
crazy it just won't go away it's a it's
a it's a virus that won't ever ever die
down well I think there's there's a
bunch of problems with this anti-semitic
thing going on and one of them is the
accomplishments of the Jews are very
disproportionate especially European
Jews if you look at European Jews and
Nobel Prize winners it's [ __ ] stagger
and European Jews were intellectuals
chess champions yeah bunch of there's a
select gene pool especially particularly
European Jews yeah we all have better
days nobody talks about that I don't
think that's true you don't think no
maybe I think I thought was fun Jews
they
and then no again okay giant people
someone's probably charged but do you
know the story of Fritz Haber Fritz
Haber is one of the most shocking Jewish
stories in terms of a Jewish scientist
who was a part of World War one on the
side of the Germans he also invented the
haba method of extracting nitrogen from
the environment you know nitrogen is one
of the most important things when it
comes to fertilizer where we talk about
fertilizers names and nitrogen is 80% of
the air we breathe most people think the
air is oxygen and carbon dioxide it's
mostly nitrogen and then there's some
oxygen and then the some carbon dioxide
that we breathe out that the plants use
fritz Harbor figured out a way to
extract nitrogen from the ax at the
actual oxygen from the actual air around
us and take that nitrogen and use it in
the soil as fertilizer and he won a
Nobel Prize for that and 50% of the
nitrogen in most people's bodies came
from the haba method like his this is
like from you know the early 1900's this
guy figured this out it's still being
used today he also was the first guy to
invent using poison gas and they use it
on the Allied troops in World War one so
he was wanted for crimes against
humanity and simultaneously winning the
Nobel Prize during World War one and
then when the Nazis took over he he
created Zyklon a Zyklon a is a it's it's
a gas that has a very distinct smell and
I think was a pesticide and they used in
Zyklon a the the smell was added to it
to make people acutely aware that this
pesticide was being used because it was
very poisonous mhm they changed it to
zyklon-b which is they used a gas the
Jews so this [ __ ] guy will created
the actual gas that was used in the
[ __ ] concentration camps to kill the
Jews and they just took the smell out of
it that's how they created zyklon-b
whatever that thing was
they added twos icon a to make it smell
bad they took that out for zyklon-b so
it was almost older --less and they were
killing people left and right with it
and he was forced out of the country I
mean it's a crazy crazy story I mean
when he was going to the front line to
help implement his gas on on the Allied
troops his wife shot herself in front of
him and he left his kid behind with his
dying wife to go to war it's [ __ ]
crazy stories crazy he wound up dying
seeking refuge away from Germany he was
one of the few scientists that they
didn't want a few Jews they didn't lock
up and he just couldn't tolerate I mean
he couldn't stand by while these other
Jews that he knew were going to the
concentration camps people are being
rounded up and he didn't you know
leaving did you know that zyklon-b
yeah I think that might have happened
like while he was while he was on the
run not sure I'd have to get into that
but I mean that would be a crazy
realization that means like the you know
the TMT got together built dynamite like
realizing what he'd done to the world I
mean how about Oppenheimer right yeah
when Oppenheimer is quoting the
bhagavad-gita we played that on the
podcast I am become death destroyer of
worlds [ __ ] man you have speaking of
billionaires being able I mean to have
that quote it's like that's a big hikes
moment yeah yeah so that mean I think
there's that is that Jews have been so
almost genetically smart for so long
there's a reason for that you know what
is it well it's that basically in the
whole of the Dark Ages the Dark Ages are
characterized by people being illiterate
that's they were in the dark and only
the clergy could read that the Jews were
a 98% literate people and that is
literally the reason if you want to talk
it actually help comes
all the way back to systemic oppression
right in the same way there are barriers
you know if you're deaf or if you're
black or if you're a woman there are
barriers you have to jump past if you
are given an advantage and it's all
evolution right then you're going to
leap forward and so when you have a
history of 500
years where no one in Europe reads
except for the Jews and the clergy well
no [ __ ] they ended up you know being at
the front lines of you know of Nobel
Prize winning in science and
intellectualism not because they're
smarter obviously but because they just
were reading that whole time hmm there's
a reason for the idea of Jewish greed -
is the doing about this is it you know
Jesus said something about usury
basically it Catholics were not okay
with lending money at interest at an
interest rate that was against the rules
right and so you're not going to lend
people money for no interest that's just
not how it works and then there were
some people that weren't subject to the
rules of Christian anti usury laws and
those for the Jews and so the Jews would
lend you money at an interest rate well
who do you hate more than anybody on
earth who's the person you wish were
dead your creditor you're the banker
that is going to foreclose on your home
and it's going to now I'm not saying
that's good or bad I also hate the
banker but that's just historically
speaking when they called use
moneylenders it's not because Jews are
like oh I'm pernicious and I want to
fill this gap it's been nobody else in
society would lend people money and so
not only were they the creditors that
people hated but they were also the
financier that made the possibility of
European you know greatness occur
because without capital without funds
you can't build a society so that is one
of the the many reasons that people have
come to hate the Jews is that they lent
them the money and that they needed and
then when it was time to come collecting
they'd be like [ __ ] this dude so
fascinating we find the root of certain
prejudices oh yeah yeah for sure that's
a good one those those two are very good
ones especially the one about being
literate I mean absolutely that makes
sense I mean yeah it wasn't until like
we're like the 1400s it's Martin Luther
that they'd asserted translating the
Bible into a phonetic alphabet we could
read it stop and think about that it's
crazy
[Applause]
[Music]